my deepest hope
is that these two intelligent capable
men have an opportunity to heal talk
this out
and reconcile chris rock isn't paying
attention to these recent comments from
jada pinkett smith et is learning new
details about the comedian's mindset
following jada's plea for he and will
smith to reconcile following the oscar
slap a source tells e.t chris is
currently touring and preparing for a
comedy special and quote he is not
concerned with the smiths at the moment
the source adds quote chris is the most
genuine person ever nothing he does is
calculated or phony and he is not caught
up in the hollywood scene he is focusing
on himself so it seems will and chris
won't be having a sit down anytime soon
despite jada's message on red table talk
now about oscar night breaking her
silence about the controversy at the red
table jada shares her hope about where
the two men can go from here my deepest
hope
is that these two intelligent capable
men have an opportunity to heal talk
this out
and reconcile the state of the world
today
we need them both and we all actually
need one another more than ever until
then
one and i are continuing to do what we
have done for the last 28 years
and let's keep figuring out this thing
called life together following the
message jada got some harsh feedback
this is going to be difficult for me
these are my peers viveka a fox who was
guest hosting the wendy williams show
got visibly upset while sharing her
reaction to jada's comments i've done a
movie with
both of them set it off with jada
and independence day with will smith
which absolutely changed my life
when i saw this video last night
it made me cry i'll be very honest with
you guys vivica goes on to explain why
she thinks jada had a role in the
infamous slap you'll recall will slapped
chris after he made a joke about jada's
shaved head a joke that didn't go over
well with jada who's made it publicly
known she struggles with alopecia a hair
loss disorder i felt to be a good
partner
there was no accountability
will smith
was defending her honor
that was why the reason he walked on
stage
and slapped
because he felt like his will his wife
had been offended so for me to see no
accountability
as a partner i have love for the smiths
i know their children i've watched them
grow up i just wish that we could have
had a little bit more accountability
um
and it for it to not seem
so
self-righteous on jada's part and that's
my fear
this also comes after jada's first
public appearance in the scandals
aftermath
she showed her support for shonda rhimes
at the grand opening of rhymes
performing arts center in los angeles
[Music]
you